[Musique]
une enquête ouverte pour homicide
volontaire après l'assassinât d'olivier
mère prêtre catholique en vendée
l'auteur présumé des faits est
actuellement en garde à vue il s'est
rendu à la gendarmerie ce matin il
s'agit du même homme responsable de l'
incendie de la cathédrale de nantes en
juillet 2020 le drame a provoqué de
nombreuses réactions politiques
gérald darmanin est actuellement sur
place
[Musique]
bars restaurants cinémas hôpitaux
transports le pass and iter est entrée
en vigueur ce matin malgré la
contestation de la rue une mesure voulue
par le gouvernement pour lutter contre
la propagation du comique 19 et alors
que les hôpitaux sont saturés en
guadeloupe et en martinique
le ministre de la santé lance un appel
aux soignants de métropole pour aider
ces deux départements en afghanistan
retour à la case départ vingt ans après
le début de l'intervention américaine
le pays passe petit à petit aux mains
des talibans elle les insurgés
contrôlent désormais six capitales
provinciales
une avancée militaire que ne semble pas
capable d'enrayer l'armée afghane qui
souffrent du retrait progressif des
troupes américaines
[Musique]
il est 20h bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt
france une enquête pour homicide
volontaire a donc été ouverte après
l'assassinât du père olivier maire
prêtre catholique de la communauté des
montfortains dans la commune de saint
laurent sur sèvre un suspect est
actuellement en garde à vue l'homme de
40 ans est originaire du rwanda a
accueilli depuis plusieurs mois par le
père olivier maire le meurtrier présumé
est déjà mise en examen pour l'incendié
de la cathédrale de nantes en juillet
2020 le ministre de l'intérieur est
actuellement sur place en vendée on va
retrouver tout de suite notre reporter
lucas léger en direct de saint laurent
sur sèvre lucas à bonsoir alors gérald
darmanin est actuellement sur place où
il s'est exprimé tout à l'heure oui
olivier gérald darmanin étaient sur
place
il est reparti il y à un peu plus d'une
heure maintenant ce qu'on peut dire sur
cette visite c'est que lé été marquée
par la présence de certains curieux qui
était à l'extérieur de ce bâtiment ce
bâtiment que vous voyez derrière moi où
a eu lieu le crime et ces personnes et
biens voulait demander des comptes à
gérald darmanin car le profil de ce
meurtrier présumé de ce criminel présumé
interpelle je vous propose d'écouter une
des personnes avec qui j'ai pu discuter
au cours de cette journée parce que je
pense que c'est malheureusement encore
une énième fois qu'on retrouve ce même
schéma
demain ce sera où ça sera quand on sait
pas on a déjà eu le cas sur d'autres
villes
ce genre d'assassinât eux mêmes dans les
églises donc je pense aujourd'hui qu'il
a encore voilà une attitude laxiste avec
un certain nombre de phénomènes
il devrait avoir un peu plus de
concertation et un peu plus de sévérité
on va dire vous l'avez dit cette affaire
a pris une tournure nettement plus
politique quand il a été rendu public
quand il a été révélé que sept personnes
avaient été impliqués et bien dans l'
incendie de la cathédrale de nantes en
juillet 2020 il avait avoué avoir allumé
plusieurs incendies la présidente
notamment du rassemblement national
s'était étonné que cette personne qui
faisait déjà l'objet d'un arrêté
d'expulsion avant ses aveux et bien
n'est pas été expulsé ce à quoi gérald
darmanin lui avait répondu dans la
journée que cette personne ne pouvait
pas être expulsé tout simplement parce
qu'elle était encore sous contrôle
judiciaire lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il a
parlé aujourd'hui devant la presse il a
fustigé la démagogie de certains de ses
opposants je vous propose de l'écouter
tout de suite certains ont cédé à la
tentation de la polémique la tentation
de la démagogie au moment où l'esprit le
corps de ce prêtre n'était pas encore en
paix le contact que j'ai eu l'honneur
avec l'église de france avec les prêtres
qui n'ont bien connu et qui ont
accueilli cette personne ici n'était pas
de ces mêmes esprits
effectivement
m'étonne plus malheureusement mais je
regrette ces polémiques qui sont
totalement infondées qui nous deux buts
dans ce coeur de l'été que fernet de la
démagogie
je vais m'arrêter là par respect envers
la famille paraît cependant la
congrégation religieuse et monsieur
poker de la république a eu l'occasion
de s'exprimer
imagine aura l'occasion de se plonger
dans les jours qui viennent son enquête
mais la polémique continue d'enfler
puisque pour les détracteurs de ce
gouvernement et bien il s'agit de la
défaillance de trop des autorités alors
même qu'il est demandé à la population
générale de faire un effort puisque
aujourd'hui
et bien c'est le jour de l'application
de la loi qui étend lusage du pass
sanitaires quoi qu'il en soit ici et
bien une enquête a été ouverte une
enquête pour homicide volontaire a
annoncé le procureur le vice procureur
de la république de la roche sur yon qui
nous a aussi a décrit est bien un
personnage qui sortait d'un séjour en
hôpital psychiatrique d'un mois il était
sorti le 29 juillet si beaucoup lucas
pour toutes ces précisions lucas léger
en direct de saint laurent sur sèvre
alors on l'entendait à l'instant des
réactions politiques très nombreuses et
très vite une politique à propos de
l'action de la justice concernant le
principal suspect
noah manoir ancien fonctionnaire de
police elle s'est exprimé à ce sujet sur
notre plateau et pour lui ce drame
révèle la faillite des institutions
judiciaires et policières du pays et
coûté 9 la france aujourd'hui est la
risée du reste de l'europe et du monde
à cause de ces lois qui n'obéissent
absolument à aucune logique donc le
ministère de l'intérieur encore une fois
comme les autorités administratives et
judiciaires malgré elles ont failli à
leur mission de sécurisation justement
du peuple français puisque ici la vendée
est un sanctuaire c'est un département
où les gens vivent en paix un
département prospère économiquement il
les risques sont extrêmement minime mais
nous sommes dans un état de
déliquescence et des compositions de
l'institution judiciaire de
l'institution policière qui est telle
qu'aujourd'hui plus rien n'est logique
et justement les citoyens ne sont pas à
l'abri des dangers habituel
la priorité de la police aujourd'hui
c'est le contrôle du pape sanitaire ce
n'est plus la lutte contre la
délinquance contre la criminalité ou
contre le terrorisme
[Musique]
l'actualité en france aujourd'hui c'est
aussi l'entrée en vigueur du pass
sanitaire antico vide place à une
première semaine de rodage et de
tolérance d'après l'exécutif
et si certains restaurateurs ont préféré
garder portes closes en signe de
contestation
d'autres ont ouvert leurs établissements
voient cela dans le centre de paris avec
mon âme ou dès lors c'est à partir
d'aujourd'hui qu'il faudra montrer patte
blanche pour prendre un café ou des
jeunes et un restaurant le sésame et
bien c'est ce pass sanitaire qu'il
faudra présenter aux restaurateurs à
l'entrée de chaque établissement
nous étions avec stéphane le gérant du
café de la crème de paris je vous
propose de l'écouter il nous a expliqué
un petit peu comment allait se passer
l'organisation aujourd'hui on est
toujours un peu un peu
voilà on peut embêter on a surtout peur
d'un confinement clairement nous notre
métier il se fait qu'à travers le
service de nos clients quoi alors qu'il
faut faire tout pour éviter un
confinement
donc là on est bien ou bien content
malgré tout de prendre les passes pour
pouvoir maintenir une activité quoi il
faut comprendre que dès l'instant où
nous nous sommes fermés on perd une
dynamique incroyable quoi nos salariés
c'est par pivot veulent plus faire ce
métier on a beaucoup de mal à recruter
vous l'avez entendu un mélange
d'appréhension et d'inquiétudes de la
part à des restaurateurs en tout cas
dans les quartiers touristiques
l'affluence est plutôt bonne les clients
sont en terrasse vous pouvez également
le voir juste derrière mans n'a pu
parler à ses clients qui estiment que
c'est plutôt une bonne chose ecoutez-le
je pense que c'est une bonne idée ça
peut éviter que les gens se contaminent
et vaudrait mieux que tout le monde soit
vaccinée pour qu'on évite que le coc
vide se propage bon alors le passé un
hyper moi je suis pour ou contre ce à la
limite je me pose pas vraiment la
question mais disons que je pense que
pour les restaurateurs effectivement
c'est une bonne chose ça leur permet de
rester ouvert après est-ce que c'est un
bon choix ça je peux pas vraiment
répondre mais je pense que pour les
restaurateurs c'est une bonne chose
ah c'est la toute première fois après de
toute manière on est un peu obligé de le
faire pour qu'on puisse sortir de la
crise donc on va faire le nécessaire
pour que tout le monde avance dans le
même sens et
et qu'on puisse enfin sortir ces
différentes va quoi on est obligé entre
guillemets 1 si on veut avancer faut
suivre la loi se passe là ni terre il
demande de l'organisation certains
établissements au même dû embaucher du
personnel à l'entrée de leur
établissement simplement pour vérifier
et checker lé pa sanitaires de leurs
clients c'est une procédure qui bien
évidemment n'enchante pas tous les
patrons mais ils vont devoir s'y plier
le porte-parole du gouvernement à
gabriel at elle a indiqué qu'une semaine
de rodage allait être accordés pour que
tous les restaurateurs puisse se mettre
en route et que cette procédure soit
normalisée
un restaurateur qui ne se plierait pas
aux règles risquerait 1500 euros damende
en tunisie chez après une récente
flambée de cas de colis les une campagne
vaccinale critiqué place à la solidarité
internationale
objectif permettre à ce pays où le taux
de mortalité lié aux coronavirus est le
plus fort d'afrique et bien de
bénéficier de millions de doses hier
plus de 500 mille tunisiens ont pu être
vaccinés et c'est un record les
précisions à tunis de bassel shellys la
plus grande opération de vaccination
jamais organisé en tunisie plus d'un
demi million de tunisiens ont reçu hier
une première dose dans les 3 135 centres
dédiés à cet effet plus de cinq cent
cinquante un mille doses administrées un
record pour cette journée nationale de
vaccination dans ce pays qui compte à
peine 12 millions d'habitants et dont le
taux de mortalité lié aux coronavirus
avait atteint des records ces dernières
semaines
plaçant la tunisie en tête des pays est
sinistrée lundi dernier c'était un appel
du président de la république qui avait
demandé à organiser la plus grande
opération de vaccination
compte tenu de la disponibilité de plus
de 6 millions de doses reçues sous forme
de dons par des voisins et les
partenaires de la tunisie c'est des
milliers de médecins infirmiers et
personnel soignant bénévoles avaient
répondu présents hier pour garantir la
réussite de cette mission je vous
propose les écouter aujourd'hui si nous
achevons la vaccination des plus de 40
ans nous commencerons la semaine
prochaine à vacciner les moins de 40 ans
d'ici au 15 septembre nous aurons vaincu
le virus ait enregistré un plus grand
nombre de vaccinations et nous aurons
ainsi surmonter et vaincu la maladie
j'ai entendu l'appel pour cette journée
d'ouverture le 8 août et je suis membre
de l'association in a rat nous avons
donc lancé un appel et rassembler un
certain nombre de jeunes hommes deux
médecins de jeunes et d'étudiants
volontaires pour faire de cette journée
de vaccination une réussite et pour
fournir le plus de moyens possibles aux
tunisiens à notre peuple afin qu'ils se
fassent vacciner et qui puisse faire
face aux épreuves auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés une journée marathon de
vaccination qui s'est fait sous le
regard attentif du président de la
république et s'est rendu dans l'un des
ses nombreux centres de vaccination à ce
rythme là la tunisie espère vacciner
l'ensemble de sa population dans les
mois à venir
à ce jour seulement 14 % de la
population ont reçu les deux doses de
vaccin premier entretien téléphonique
entre emmanuel macron et le nouveau
président iranien a les deux hommes ont
parlé de la relance de l'accord de 2015
sur le nucléaire
emmanuel macron s'est montré catégorique
sur la question en appelant téhéran à
reprendre rapidement les négociations
afin d'aboutir à un compromis président
de la république a appelé l'iran à
reprendre rapidement les négociations à
vienne afin d'aboutir à leur conclusion
est à mettre un terme sans délai à
toutes les activités nucléaires qu'il
poursuit en violation de l'accord et de
son côté le nouveau président iranien
ebrahim raïssi a insisté sur
l'importance de garantir je cite les
droits de thé ans dont toute négociation
les droits du peuple iranien doivent
être préservées et les intérêts de notre
nation garantit les américains ont
clairement violé leurs obligations en
imposant de nouvelles sanctions
alexandre lukashenko réaffirme sa
légitimité en tant que dirigeant de la
biélorussie un an après sa réélection
décrié alexandre loukachenko s'est
exprimé aujourd'hui lors d'une
conférence de presse il a de nouveau
tenu a proclamé sa victoire grâce à un
scrutin je cite totalement transparent
face à une opposition qui préparait un
coup d'état le président biélorusse
s'est aussi défendu de toute allégeance
à la russie écoutez le nous sommes un
état souverain et indépendant
notre peuple après s'y être devenu après
plusieurs siècles souverain et
indépendant et quand j'entends toutes
ces insinuations concernant le
rattachement à la russie et tout ça je
pense toujours moi comme si j'étais à la
place de poutine écoute la russie at
elle besoin de problèmes en plus non et
c'est comme ça que le président russe le
voit le monde a changé et pour
s'intégrer pour encourager l'intégration
dans l'industrie comme vous l'avez si
bien dit et dans l'économie en général
il ne faut pas forcément incorporé
quelque chose et les états unis
durcissent les sanctions contre le
gouvernement biélorusse selon la maison
blanche alexandre loukachenko et
responsable je cite de violations
continues des libertés démocratiques des
droits humains et des règles
internationales
pour plus de précision va tout de suite
retrouvé notre correspondant à
washington thomas bowness
bonsoir thomas alors washington accentue
la pression sur minsk en infligeant une
nouvelle salve de sanctions contre le
pouvoir biélorusse thomas à qui est-ce
qui est concerné 1 par ces nouvelles
mesures de la maison blanche est bien
dans cette nouvelle salve de sanctions
annoncées ce lundi par washington 23
personnes et 21 organisations sont visés
par ces nouvelles sanctions parmi elles
on trouve notamment le comité national
olympique de biélorussie une sanction
qui fait suite à la faire de cet athlète
biélorusse aux jeux olympiques qui a
affirmé être victime d'une tentative de
rapatriement forcé washington qui estime
par ailleurs que ce comité national
olympique de biélorussie est coupable de
faciliter le blanchiment d'argent dans
ces listes d'entreprises qui sont visées
par ces sanctions américaines on trouve
aussi l'entreprise bayrou skalli qui est
une entreprise qui produit de l'engrais
en biélorussie et c'est une entreprise
qui figurait sur une liste qui a
transmis à l'époque l'opposante ce but
la nati canucks callas lorsqu'elle est
venue ici aux etats unis elle a affirmé
avoir donné une liste aux autorités
américaines lors donc de sa visite à la
maison blanche reçu par joe biden
c'était le 28 juillet dernier je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu elle déclaré à
la sortie de sa rencontre avec le
président américain
s'il s'agit d'une rencontre très
importante d'un message adressé au monde
entier que le plus grand pays du monde
est avec nous et cette rencontre est
comme la victoire de tous les
biélorusses qui se battent dans le monde
c'est en quelque sorte une inspiration
pour notre peuple pour aller de l'avant
ne pas abandonner
même si les gens n'abandonne pas c'est
certain mais c'est un signal
supplémentaire que nous avons des alliés
forts à nos côtés mais saâdane
le soutien affiché de joe biden à cette
opposante biélorusse ainsi que ces
sanctions ont pour but est d'accentuer
la pression sur le président loukachenko
au washington qui réclame l'organisation
d'une nouvelle élection présidentielle
en biélorussie alors que loukachenko lui
l'a dit vous l'avez diffusé à l'antenne
il a réaffirmé ce lundi sa victoire et a
dénoncé la préparation d'un coup d'état
par les figures d'opposition s'étaient
donc l'an dernier minsk qui fustige
régulièrement l'attitude des pays
occidentaux les etats-unis en tête à qui
ils reprochent leur proximité avec un
certain nombre de figures d'opposition
et d'être derrière un certain nombre de
manifestations qui se sont déroulées ces
derniers mois en biélorussie ces
nouvelles sanctions annoncées ce lundi
par washington font suite à d'autres
sanctions qui avait été prononcée au
mois de juin suite à la faire de ce vol
ryanair qui s'était posé en biélorussie
il faut noter enfin que les premières
sanctions prononcées par les etats-unis
à l'égard de la biélorussie remonte un
peu puisqu'elle ont été prononcées en
2006 à l'époque le président s'était de
george w bush
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnet en direct de
washington
les talibans étendent leur emprise en
afghanistan il contrôle désormais six
capitales provinciales dont quatre
depuis hier une offensive amorcée en mai
au début du retrait prose et progressif
des troupes américaines et que sont
incapables d'enrayer l'armée afghane
retour sur les derniers événements avec
amaya souplesse scènes de chaos à
koundouz est désormais aux mains des
talibans en afghanistan
les provinces tombent les unes après les
autres et le cauchemar se poursuit pour
ce pays qui vit quotidiennement dans la
terreur depuis le début de l'offensive
des insurgés en mai le groupe gagne du
terrain et met en difficulté les troupes
afghanes qui deviennent de plus en plus
vulnérables le nord de l'afghanistan est
encerclée par les talibans qui ont pris
le contrôle de plusieurs capitales
provinciales ces derniers jours selon un
responsable sécuritaire le gouvernement
ne parvient pas à envoyer de l'aide et
les troupes ont dû se retirer au profit
des talibans dans la province de kunar
les habitants se déplacent en nombre
pour fuir les combats
leur quotidien précaire est incertain et
rythmée par les attaques se moquer les
banh et là il y avait de violents
combats dans notre village nous avons
fui nos maisons à cause des combats et
de la fin après avoir marché pendant
deux nuits
nous sommes venus ici la première nuit
nous étions dans un parc
puis nous sommes venus dans cette école
où nous vivons avec des problèmes
nous avions une belle vie dans notre
village nous avions tous mais à cause
des combats entre les forces de sécurité
les talibans tout a été détruit
comme vous le voyez toutes ces familles
se sont juste sauver ils ont laissé des
maisons pleines
les talibans ont pillé les matériaux de
nos maisons des offensives révélatrice
de la stratégie des insurgés de
s'attaquer désormais aux centres urbains
après avoir d'abord porté leurs attaques
sur les campagnes et les pourtours
frontaliers face à l'affaiblissement des
forces du pays
les affrontements entre les deux camps
se font de plus en plus rare et la prise
de territoire devient de plus en plus
facile pour les talibans une avancée qui
s'accélère fortement depuis le début du
retrait des troupes américaines qui
devrait être achevé le 31 août prochain
et pour en parler on va retrouver tout
de suite david rigoulet roze il est
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique
david rigoulet roze bonsoir merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france on
voyait la situation en afghanistan se
détériore de jour en jour six capitales
provinciales sont désormais contrôlées
par les talibans tout ça en l'espace de
quatre jours mais est ce que on pouvait
s'y attendre finalement il ya une
accélération de la dynamique
effectivement au profit des talibans
qu'il ya une stratégie très élaboré un
ils ont probablement été sous-estimée
dans leur stratégie
effectivement il ya une implantation
ancien dans l'est dans les zones rurales
il ya eu la stratégie de prise de
contrôle des points frontaliers on l'a
vu ces dernières semaines et maintenant
la sociaux les villes alors on peut
s'interroger sur les problèmes de
des forces gouvernementales il ya
évidemment un problème de logistique
très important puisqu'il n'y a plus le
support logistique aérien américain ou
ou de manière marginale
d'ailleurs on peut on peut noter qu'il
ya un ciblage systématique par les
talibans des pilotes
arguant qu'ils soient d'hélicoptères ou
de jets justement pour empêcher un
support aérien
et puis il ya un probablement dans
l'assaut des villes l'entrée et l'entrée
en scène de ce que rappelle sarah quita
kelly l'unité rouge c'est un groupe de
choc en fait des deux soeurs de forces
spéciales des talibans qui sont très
opérationnels on n'est plus avec les
talibans de des années 80 94 96 c'est
plus du tout la même chose il ya il ya
une professionnalisation sur le plan
opérationnel et c'est manifestement ce
qui fait la différence malgré malgré la
supériorité numérique suppose et de
l'armée afghane parce que effectivement
concernant l'armée afghane
on a le sentiment qu'elle semble
incapable finalement de stopper
l'avancée des taliban alors c'est un
manque de moyens avant tout pas
seulement
oui le problème de la gamme c'est que
c'est théoriquement ces trois cent mille
effectif
mais en réalité en termes opérationnels
c'est beaucoup moins et puis surtout
ceux qui sont les plus efficaces à ceux
qui ont été formés par les américains
sont les forces spéciales à les
commandos mais les commandos sont
employés sur des théâtres où ils n'ont
pas lieu d'être employé c'est le
problème et une confusion des genres
ce qui fait que l'efficacité qui
pourraient être les leurs justement pour
reprendre des points d'appui d'une
certaine manière et d'évaluer parce
qu'une grande partie des troupes
régulier en fait ne combat pas il ya une
débandade et donc il ya de ce point de
vue là effectivement il ya une
inadéquation opérationnelle sur le
terrain qui profite aux talibans qui
sont fort bien entraînée par ailleurs à
un manque d'efficacité de l'armée
afghane également liée au retrait total
des soldats américains ont fait en tout
cas son retrait est prévu pour le pour
le 31 août
ce retrait est effectivement un impact
aussi opérationnels sur l'armée afghane
oui c'est essentiellement le soutien
aérien qui a toujours fait la différence
lorsqu'il y avait
la question de la sauce sur les villes
notamment koundouz qui vient d'être
primé elle avait été déjà prise à deux
reprises et elle avait été reconquise on
va dire par les forces gouvernementales
grâce à l'appui aérien américain qui
s'est manifesté d'ailleurs dans le sud à
kandahar qui a fait momentanément la
différence il en sait très bien que
c'est reculer pour mieux sauter parce
que de toute façon à partir du 31 août
la question de ce soutien aérien ne se
posera plus opérationnellement et et ça
va accentuer les faiblesses
effectivement intrinsèque de l'armée de
l'art de l'armée afghane
notamment parce qu'il ya un défaut
logistique en termes de 1 des armes
aériennes pour le suivi de dés des
équipements la logistique etc
et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui elle
l'armée ne sont pas en mesure de faire
front sur l'ensemble de théâtre où les
talibans font mettre la pression alors
l'intervention américaine en afghanistan
débuté il ya 20 ans a été très critiqué
à l'époque les citoyens à vauban est ce
qu'il me finalement eh bien ils vont pas
regretter ce départ des américains selon
vous ben c'est très ambivalents parce
que l'obsession aujourd'hui de deux
redit des citoyens en tout cas de la
population à gaza et parvenir à une
situation pacifiée et les algues en sont
épuisés par des décennies de guerre
non pas qu'ils apprécient les talibans
loin là d'ailleurs il ya eu des
manifestations de soutien à l'armée dans
les villes sur les toits que ça soit à
kaboul ou dans d'autres grandes villes
mais en même temps cette situation de
guerre permanente la mine la population
la population afghane
toutes confessions et ethnies confondues
et c'est d'une certaine manière c'est
aussi ce qui profite aux talibans qui
vont se présenter comme potentiellement
les restaurateurs d'une forme de
stabilité même si c'est alors à leurs
conditions
du coup l'ol l'ua a tenu une réunion il
ya quelques jours au sujet de la
situation en afghanistan
quel pourrait être à l'avenir les
différentes postures de la communauté
internationale là on est d'une certaine
manière dont le
dans le théâtre effectivement de ce
qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale parce que la communauté
internationale c'est quoi c'est de toute
façon une juxtaposition d'intérêts
géopolitiques convergent au
contradictoire et en l'occurrence les
américains ont décidé de se retirer et
ne reviendront pas à priori
effectivement à ces actes et et après
celle paradoxalement c'est l'inquiétude
des pays limitrophes qui stigmatise et
régulièrement la présence occidentale et
américaine en particulier qui
aujourd'hui finissent presque si j'ose
dire par regretter la relative stabilité
que ça apporte et même si aujourd'hui il
ya effectivement un grand jeu quitte à
l'oeuvre entre les différents acteurs
russie chine inde 1 pour voir ce qui
pourrait advenir effectivement de ce
carrefour cimetière des empires mais ce
carrefour effectivement de l'asie de
l'est asie centrale merci beaucoup david
rigoulet roze d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la revue orient
stratégique au nigeria sept ans après
son enlèvement une jeune fille a été
libérée par boko haram c'est l'une des
276 lycéenne enlevé par le groupe
islamique en avril 2014 la nouvelle on
se souvient avait soulevé une grande
vague de colère et d'indignation à des
années après boko haram continue de
faire régner la terreur dans le nord-est
du pays et multiplient chez les
enlèvements pierre pissavy yvernault
maxime buathier
sept ans après avoir été enlevé par boko
haram cette jeune femme peut enfin
rentrer chez elle
c'est en avril 2014 que le groupe
terroriste la kidnappe avec près de 300
de ses camarades h ebook dans le
nord-est du pays
si la plupart ont été libérées ont
retrouvé une centaine restent toujours
portées disparues pour le gouverneur de
l'état de borno
le travail pour obtenir le retour de
toutes les filles n'est pas encore
terminée
comme nous espérons récupérer d'autres
très bientôt
le gouvernement de l'état de borno
collabore avec l'armée nigériane et
d'autres forces de sécurité nous allons
mettre en place une structure qui nous
permettra d'en retrouver davantage
nous appelons les parents défi de she
boc a à coopérer avec le gouvernement de
l'état de borno et l'armée nigériane
afin que nous puissions travailler
ensemble et déterminer comment récupérer
les autres filles
depuis l'enlèvement des lycéennes de
chine boc
les kidnappings du genre se multiplient
dans le nord du pays en plus de boko
haram de multiples bandes aux
affiliations diverses et lourdement
armés qualifiés de bandits sévices le
but obtenir des rançons de la part du
gouverneur et des familles des rapts qui
se sont multipliées cette année depuis
le mois de décembre près de 1000 élèves
ont été kidnappés dernière en date le 5
juillet dernier
121 lycéens ont été enlevés par le
groupe terroriste
si plusieurs d'entre eux ont été libérés
ils sont encore nombreux à rester entre
les griffes de boko haram c'est la fin
de cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi prochain point sur l'actualité ce
sera dans une trentaine de minutes
rester avec nous sur rt france à tout
[Musique]